15 minutes and 25 seconds into the 1986
World Cup match between Argentina and
England Diego Maradona did something
infants
this moment goes down in history because
of what the commentators could clearly
see that is why England is so Furious
Maradona has punched it in with his left
hand but in 1986 referees didn't have
access to instant replays they had to
make judgment calls from the field based
on their limited perspective on what
happened and their subjective view on it
was that this goal was good this would
never happen today as technology has
empowered referees to view moments again
and again from multiple different angles
before making a final decision and this
year's World Cup features a technology
that takes that a step further judging
when someone is offside using AI
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so the the simplest way of explaining
offsides is that the offensive player
has to have two defensive players
between them and the goal or be behind
where the ball is most of the time it's
the goalkeeper plus one Defender for the
most part if any offensive players are
behind this second to last Defender
while the ball is in play they're
offside that's Jeremiah oshan by the way
soccer editor of SB Nation
offside should be an objective call
either you're in front of this line or
behind it what makes it tricky is that
we're often judging with subjective
perspectives and it can be hard to tell
when a player is teetering over the line
as this tweet by Dale Johnson of ESPN
shows the angle at which you see
something really matters
these two images from the March 20th
game between Liverpool and Nottingham
Forest show the same moment in time from
two slightly different perspectives in
the image on the left number 20 looks
like he's in front of number three but
on the right it looks like their
positions are inverted if audience
members only see an angle they feel is
uncompelling it can leave them unsure
that the right call was made
like in this October 7th game between
England and the us maybe they're looking
at an offside call potentially but it
looks like Sophia Smith is on side this
call shocked even the commentators
right there is where they're saying
Sophia's offside already this goal would
have tied the match at 2-2 but because
it was revoked England won two to one it
was revoked in part because of VAR video
assisted referees were introduced in
2018 with the intention of making calls
like this a little more objective these
refs are in a room away from the match
but they have the advantage of seeing
the event from 33 camera angles if they
see something they think a referee
didn't or couldn't have seen they can
suggest that the footage be reviewed on
the field monitor this enhances the
accuracy and objectivity of calls but it
still relies on perspective
for the 2022 World Cup FIFA is
introducing semi-automated AI offside
technology
a sensor in the ball will relay its
position on the field 500 times a second
and 12 motion cameras mounted underneath
the roof of stadiums we use machine
learning to triangulate players body
positions this data can be used to
create a 3D visualization of a play that
can be viewed from any angle like in
this early test during a September match
the virtual camera is able to fly around
giving an almost Godlike perspective of
the scenario there are no viewing angle
limitations no frame rate delays it's a
near one-to-one Recreation of the event
seemingly indisputable evidence for
referees and audience members that this
player's name was offside by this much
subjectivity isn't being totally removed
from the equation though the technology
being only semi-automated means that
human referees will still make the final
calls after taking what the AI shows
under consideration and that can be
critical because while this Tech can
judge space flawlessly it can't see
everything like a player's intentions
there was a an MLS game between lafc and
Austin FC where a foul potentially
occurred the referee decided not to give
the penalty for subjective reasons which
was you know his touch was taking him
away from the ball which implied that
maybe he wasn't really fouled as as much
as the replay made it kind of look like
he was and I thought that was actually a
really good use of VAR where he clearly
was shown what happened and he was
allowed to make a decision about whether
or not he he thought it was a foul or
not
semi-automated AI offside Tech is meant
to make referees less reliant on
subjective perspective but it's just a
tool how it'll change gameplay depends
on how it gets used and ultimately how
it gets reconciled with what a human
being sees on the field
[Music]
offside is a complicated Rule and this
video only scratches the surface on it
but the new semi-automated AI offside
system is already at work at the World
Cup according to ESPN in an early match
between Qatar and Ecuador the system
made a correct offside call and the 3D
representation gave fans Clarity over a
play that was somewhat hard to see
though there also seems to be some
dissatisfaction over how long it took to
make that decision
in a game between Argentina and Saudi
Arabia though the call is made much
faster ultimately while this Tech can
give human referees information more
quickly their decisions will always take
some time